le coaching au féminin on n'a pas
beaucoup d' aspiration qui se sont
rendus à un haut niveau dans le coaching
derrière le banc des carabins mélodie
daoust fait ses classes
après sa carrière de hockeyeur le métier
d'entraîneur chef pourrait devenir le
ciel mais effectué une percée dans un
milieu plutôt réfractaire à la présence
de femmes demain défi de taille
oui irène définitivement brick lane des
femmes dirigées par des hommes
c'est la norme pourtant le canada
dispose aujourd'hui d'un bassin
remarquable de candidates
guylaine demers a co présidé un groupe
de travail sur la place des femmes et
des filles dans le sport et son constat
est sans équivoque il ya vraiment une
résistance du système que les femmes
n'ont pas accès au coaching qui on est
ici au canada l'on parle pas d'un pays
d'afrique du nord aux jeux olympiques de
londres en 2012
à peine 20% des entraîneurs de la
délégation canadienne étaient des femmes
en 2016 rio la représentation féminine a
chuté à 16% et entre les jeux d'hiver de
2014 et 2018
les femmes ont aussi perdu du galon une
régulation généralisée à tous les
niveaux et à ce point préoccupante que
guylaine demers recommande au
gouvernement de punir les fédérations
sportives qui ne font pas assez de place
aux femmes
on a beaucoup insisté sur l'imputabilité
donc cette notion de rendre des comptes
il faut que les fédérations et des
comptes à rendre pour qu'ils puissent
avoir accès aux financements alors si on
fait juste leur dis bien essayer de
faire votre possible mais ça fonctionne
pas faire son possible
holger et cac est l'exception elle a été
la première femme en amérique du nord a
dirigé une équipe universitaire
masculine de basketball
accepter par ses joies mais souvent
repoussé par ce n'est pas elle c'était
pas ma place il me respecte et parce que
j'ai j'ai eu du succès mais c'était fini
la même quand j'ai gagné deux fois au
niveau que les gels l'entraîneur de
l'année au niveau que les jeunes à
travers le canada sont pas même pauvres
venus me féliciter
en dépit de cette résistance orgueil
rica qui invite les femmes à foncer
lorsque le moment est propice
tout est possible
c'est juste il faut croire ce que tu
fais il ya des bonnes femmes qui
peuplent qui font du bon travail comme
coach oui oui comme coach mais est
connecté la pression est forte pour que
ceux qui dictent des règles à suivre
modifient leurs proches
ce qu'on se rend compte c'est que les
organisations sportives vont souvent
recrutés dans le même bassin de
personnes
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer que pour
engager l'entraîneur chef d'une équipe
masculine on va avoir quatre femmes pour
passer une entrevue
je suis certaine que les gens
parleraient tout de suite mais quand ces
quatre hommes qui parlent ce entrevue
pour engager une femme on questionne pas
cette situation là qu'est de la fidh
selon mélodies de où les sportives ont
cruellement besoin de modèles vinyle
faut développer beaucoup plus de femmes
pour pouvoir coacher des institutions
féminine mais aussi pour juste parce
qu'on veut des femmes mais parce qu'ils
sont bonnes jean françois poirier
radio-canada monde